Well, I think that, you know,
in terms of value of understanding the nervous system
and where it can be steered,
it's absolutely clear that the nervous system can change
in response to experience,
so, this thing we call neuroplasticity is really that,
it's the brain's ability to modify itself
in response to experience
and I think it's important to understand that
from birth till about age 25,
the brain is extremely malleable
in a kind of almost passive way where,
kids are exposed to things and the brain is just wiring up,
I mean, the brain is really designed to adjust itself
in order to be in concert with its surroundings
and to optimize that, just the way we described
a minute ago.
Like the way that a child
can learn a language very quickly
or play the guitar.
Or three languages,
yeah, without an accent.
Something like that.
You know, three languages without an accent,
it's remarkable and try and do that after age 25,
it's very challenging and so,
the brain is basically designed to be customized
in the early part of life,
and then to implement those algorithms
in that circuitry for the rest of its life.
And so, the brain can change in adulthood
and it can change provided that there's
an emphasis on some perceptual event.
So, in other words,
if you wanna change your brain as an adult,
let's say you wanna be less anxious,
you wanna learn a new language,
you wanna be more functional in some way, presumably,
the key thing is to bring focus
to some particular perception
of something that's happening during the learning process
and the reason for that
is that there's a neurochemical system
involving acetylcholine,
and it comes from these two little nuclei
down in the base of the brain called nucleus basalis.
All day long, you're doing things in a reflexive way,
but when you do something
and you think about it very intensely,
acetylcholine is released from basalis
at the precise neurons that were involved in that behavior
and it marks those for change
during sleep or during deep rest later.
So, for people that wanna change their brain,
the power of focus is really the entry point
and the ability to access a deep rest and sleep
because most people don't realize this but
neuro-plasticity is triggered by intense focus,
but neuroplasticity occurs during deep sleep and rest
and we can talk about
how to optimize those different brain functions.
One of the things that's really important
also to think about how the brain works
in terms of plasticity and all this stuff is
what the brain really wants to do is also pass as much of
what it does off to reflexive behavior as possible.
(Rich laughs)
So, when we're talking about focus,
I think it can get a little bit vague
but it might be useful to think about like
what exactly is focus and what triggers plasticity?
So, the brain loves to be able to just do things
pick up coffee cups and drink and walk and talk
and do things and not put much energy into it.
When we decide to focus, what the brain really does
is it switches on a set of circuits that involve
the frontal cortex and nucleus basalis and some others
and it's trying understand duration,
how long something's gonna last,
path, what's gonna happen and outcome,
what ultimately is gonna happen?
So, duration, path and outcome.
You know, the events of early 2020
are a good example of this.
One of the reasons why it's so exhausting
to be alive in 2020 is because
we are now having to pay attention
to duration, path and outcome.
How long is this thing gonna last?
You know, when are they gonna open up all businesses?
Did I touch that door handle?
Does it matter?
Right.
Who are the experts?
Are there any experts?
You know, there are a lot of questions, whereas normally,
we can just move through life
without having to do all that analysis.
So, if it's a simple example
like trying to learn a new language or a new motor skill
or a new way of conceptualizing something,
maybe somebody is in a therapeutic process
and they're trying to work through a trauma
or something like that,
duration, path and outcome is
built into the networks of the brain,
we can do that very easily, but it takes work
and it almost has a feeling
of underlying agitation and frustration
and that's because the circuits that turn on
before acetylcholine are of the stress system.
So, when you or I decide we're gonna learn something
and really dig in,
norepinephrine, which is adrenaline,
is secreted in the brainstem and in the body
and it brings about a state of alertness.
Then our attention which is mostly a diffuse light
is brought to a particular
duration, path and outcome analysis,
this would be thinking about what somebody is saying,
what are they really trying to say?
A hard passage of reading,
a hard set of math problems,
you know, a challenging physical workout.
When you do that, these two systems have to work very hard
and the adult brain
doesn't really wanna change the algorithms
it learned in childhood,
but if you do those two things you have alertness and focus,
the acetylcholine and the norepinephrine
converged to mark those synopsis for change.
So, the way to think about neuro-plasticity
if one wants to change their brain is,
bring about the most intense concentration
you can to something
and then later bring about
the least amount of concentration to that thing.
So, I'll talk about that in a second but
there were some studies that were done at Stanford
by a guy named Eric Knudsen that showed that
plasticity in the adult brain, any age,
can be as robust as it is in childhood,
as fast and as traumatic.
Wow.
Provided the focus is there and it's all contingent
on this acetylcholine molecule coming from nucleus basalis.
So you say, well, how do you do that?
How do you get it?
Yeah, exactly.
Well, I've got friends that chew Nicorette
thinking that's gonna get them there
because Nicorette is a nicotinic acetylcholine agonist,
but that's gonna globally increase acetylcholine
so, I always tell them that's not the right approach.
The right approach is to bring as much focus to a behavior
or to a thought or to an action pattern,
and there has to be a sense of urgency.
So, what Knudsen lab showed and another lab at UCSF,
Mike Merzenich's lab showed is that,
if there's a serious contingency,
like in order to get your ration of food each day
you have to learn this thing,
the degree of plasticity is remarkable.
Right.
But if there isn't an incentive,
it just isn't gonna happen.
So, these circuits in the brain that mother nature set up
are designed to be anchored to a real need
and people always say to me, well,
should I do something out of love and a real desire to learn
or should it be out of fear?
But either one works.
The sense of urgency is just acetylcholine
and it's norepinephrine, that's all it is.
It doesn't, the brain doesn't have a recognition
of whether or not something is
pleasureful or not until later.
Once you start accomplishing your goal,
the reward systems like dopamine start kicking in,
but I think if people are interested
in modifying their brain for the better,
at least some, you know, top contour understanding of how
urgency and focus must converge for that to happen
can be useful because
I think there's a lot of attention paid to
whether or not something feels like flow
or whether or not see what I call, highly desirable states
or whether or not you can eat a plant out of the ground
that will magically put your brain
into a state of plasticity and the answer is, yes,
such plants exist
but what's missing is the focus component.
If that work is not done with a particular end goal in mind,
you'll get plasticity
but you'll get plasticity in a kind of across the board.
It's like learning nine lang,
learning a little bit of nine languages all at once
is not gonna make you speak coherently in any one of them.
So, focus is the key
Right, I mean, this idea flow
is so much in the vernacular now and
my sense is that people are trying to measure
their level of engagement against some
sort of theoretical idea of what it's like to be
in that flow state
and if they're not experiencing it,
they feel like they're doing it wrong or they're,
they feel guilty or they beat themselves up
and for me it's, a lot of it is just hard work.
Like, right now,
I'm trying to finish this book
and I should've been working on this book
for like the last nine months, right,
and I just couldn't get it together,
like it's a collaborative project
so, there's a lot of different people
that are involved in this
and they've been working diligently sort of daily,
you know, putting this thing together and
I've just been focusing on the podcast
and been unable to immerse myself in this project
because I know from past book projects, when I go in,
I go all in, like the addict in me kicks in and it's like,
it just becomes my universe
and I've been completely paralyzed from taking that on.
And so, I've dithered away most of the quarantine
without being productive on this project
and then about 10 days ago,
we had a meeting and we established this deadline
at, you know, July 10th to turn this thing in
and it was like a switch got flicked and I went all in
and it's all I can think about now
and in fact, everything else feels like
extraneous and a distraction.
I just wanna get back so I can focus on this thing and
10 days ago, I couldn't get myself into that position
and it's made me think about
like, what is going on in my brain that, you know,
it's such a drastic state change
and what did I do to switch that
while a deadline was imposed upon me
and whatever happened neurochemically with that
set in motion like a chain reaction of events
that got me into the chair and once I began the project,
for me, it's all about like momentum, right?
It's like this start,
getting to the starting line and beginning is so hard.
Like, I will just go forever without doing it
and then I'm in and then I'm all in 110%,
and I'm like, why can't I just,
why can't I be that person who just worked on it, you know,
an hour and a half every day for the last three months?
I can offer some potential explanations.
(Rich laughs)
I can relate.
And none of it involves a flow state.
Right.
It's all hard.
Yeah and you know, I'm friends with Steven Kotler,
I think Flow and I think the cheeks in MOHAI
who originated the state thing and Flow
is really interesting, but I say right now
the most we can say about Flow mechanistically is
backwards, It spells wolf.
We don't really understand flow.
People have come up with these theories it's like,
you know, hypo hyper frontallis,
I haven't seen the data and I'm not picking on anybody,
I'm putting that out there as a prompt
for people to discover this.
I think that and to work on it.
I think it's a really interesting, highly desirable state,
but I think we need to get comfortable
as a culture in trying to understand our species
and how we work,
that the early stages of hard work and focus
are gonna feel like agitation, stress and confusion,
because that's the norepinephrine
and adrenaline system kicking in.
None of us would expect to walk into the gym
and do our PR lift, or, you know,
perform or go do something without warming up.
The brain also needs to warm up and start to hone in
which circuits are gonna be active,
and, it's unreasonable for us to think,
Oh, I've got an hour, I'm gonna plop down and write
beautifully for an hour, my best work.
We need to accept that there's a period
of agitation and stress that accompanies the
dropping into these highly concentrated states.
I do think attentional bandwidth is a real issue
but I also see a lot of opportunity
coming from these two
emergencies and our reaction to them
with the central thing being just that normal is over and
I am very glad about that because
normal was leading us straight to catastrophe
and you know, this is, I think this is an opportunity
to create a new normal with for example,
green new deal as the stimulus that puts people back to work
and also the fact that
the public has experienced in education about
emergency situations,
about how we can act together in order to protect life
and radically alter the economy in order to protect life.
Yeah, just at what is possible for an emergency response.
Suddenly Congress comes up with $2 trillion.
Suddenly everyone can work from home.
Suddenly people don't have to fly across the planet.
Like, these changes are possible
and they can happen very quickly.
The public's also getting an education about
exponential risk
and exponential acceleration of existential risk.
The fact that these things happen on a curve
and you have to respond as soon as possible
or else they can get away from you.
Yeah, I think that's certainly
a lesson that everybody is taking from this and
there's definitely this sense of being awakened
from the sleeping self, I guess, on some level,
and so, with that, let's take it back a little bit,
I mean, how did your awakening occur
with respect to your advocacy around climate?
I mean, I know it had to do with Sandy
so, if you could just like, you know, tell that story,
I think it would be informative.
So, I came to New York City
in 2009 to pursue my clinical psychology PhD and
Hurricane Irene happened,
Hurricane Sandy happened or Super Storm Sandy and
as I was walking around my neighborhood
in the days following
and just seeing all of this destruction, so much damage, I,
there was a car with a smashed windshield
and someone had put a sign on it that said,
is global warming the culprit?
And when I saw that, it's like my stomach dropped,
you know, I, 'cause I knew
and that's what's so amazing with the climate emergency is
there's so much awareness about the emergency and so little
both discussion and action.
So, that sign helped me become actually aware
of what I already knew, if that makes sense.
So, yeah, the process of aware of the emergency
happened through those events as well as for many years,
I was in denial and especially had
practiced willful ignorance,
meaning I knew that this was a scary situation
so, I just would avoid it,
at like sometimes I would read the first few lines
of an article on climate and then say,
Oh, my God, I can't handle this, you know, X and,
but as I was
getting older and also through my own psychotherapy,
I was just getting, you know, internally stronger
and more able to not do that, to actually look at this.
So, my awareness was kind of growing
but what really changed my life from which there's
like, it's a clear kind of before and after
and there's no going back, is my good friend said to me,
I was planning,
I was very alarmed and I was planning to do some writing,
I was planning to be kind of a climate
commentator or an author
and my friend said to me, don't start a blog,
discourse isn't enough, think what could you do
to actually solve this problem?
And it was like my brain exploded because
it's like it had, I had never thought about it like that.
I was an academic, I was a student, the idea of,
I've been a little bit involved in politics but not really
so, the idea of, Oh, actually try to solve this
huge global emergency, it's just too big to think of
but when he threw down that gauntlet, I just realized,
Oh, that's it for me, right,
that's the only thing that I want is to,
as we say at the climate mobilization,
canceled the apocalypse.
Right.
And I've been on that mission
for the past six years.
Well, what's interesting is that
you've been able to leverage this specific skillset
that you have towards that solution,
and when we kind of canvas the climate emergency,
there's many on-ramps here.
You could have been a commentator, a journalist, a writer
an author on this subject matter in general,
there's political battles that we can pick,
there's technological innovation
that can help solve this problem,
but fundamentally, if you wanna get to the root
of what's arresting the level
or the rate at which we can address
and overcome these problems,
it really does boil down to our psychological makeup
and how we're thinking about this issue
because that's the true barrier
towards us actually doing anything about it.
You know, I come from addiction recovery
and there's a certain architecture in your steps
that remind me of the 12 steps specifically,
you know, acceptance and breaking these chains of denial
that are so important to solving any personal problem,
but on top of that, I'm also like plant-based
I'm part of the vegan community and I'm very aware of
the various strategies that are deployed
within that subculture to try to convince other people
that becoming vegan is a good thing to do,
with varying degrees of success and failure
and I think in the Venn diagram
there's an overlap that's applicable
to the conversation around environmentalism
because your entry point and on-ramp is so relatable.
It's not that we're not aware that there's a problem,
it's the extent to which we're really willing to face it
and then translate that increased level of awareness
into some kind of tangible action
that potentially can actually make a difference.
Absolutely, and I would just add to that
that it's awesome that you're
vegan and part like, a leader in that movement,
that's obviously extremely important for
animal agriculture and industrial agriculture,
it's such a huge contributor to the climate emergency
and just general ecological emergency
and, you know, there's been such huge movement towards
being plant-based and all sorts of meat alternatives
going more mainstream, I mean, so,
that is a really exciting development,
and the truth is there's
lots of really exciting developments in the climate space.
Bicycling is resurgent
and solar panels are continually getting
more efficient and cheaper
and new technologies are being created
and so forth and so forth, but it's about
scaling it all up, like by 1000 times,
something that only Federal governments have
the resources to do is the kind of system change,
It's all there, It's all ready to go,
We just have lacked the political will to implement it
and I agree with you that
that is significantly because of psychological factors
and I think what the climate emergency movement is doing
is intervening in that,
realizing that our enemy is not just fossil fuel companies
and their huge network and industrial agriculture,
but also denial, that denial and pacivity are also enemies.
In terms of
the protocols that we should all be undertaking to,
you know, buttress our microbiome,
you're not necessarily advising a very,
a specific type of diet other than to say,
plant diversity is king, like
this is the vector of all factors for you, right?
So, it's not about, oh, it's vegan or, I mean,
it's a predominantly plant-based or plant-based diet
but the diversity of plants is really what's important
in terms of making sure that you're doing everything you can
in the interest of your microbiome.
Well, I think the critical piece to me, so,
you know, the book is called "Fiber Fuels"
and that's because I feel like fiber has been this
ignored super food.
Well, it also needs a new publicist.
It does really need a new publicist.
You are that you are that publicist,
You are, yes, you're hired.
I'm the guy.
So, yeah, no, I'm here to fight on behalf of fiber
and get it back on the map and part of the conversation
because you know, we've been ignoring it
and part of it is that we've been thinking about it
as this orange drink that grandma's stirs up
so that she can poop,
when in fact it's incredible,
the connection between fiber and our gut microbiome.
You know, fiber doesn't just go in the mouth
and shoot out the other end.
Soluble fiber is a specific sort of general category
which feeds the microbiome, this is their preferred food
and when we give this to them
they consume it, they grow stronger,
our microbes actually multiply, grow stronger,
and then they turn around and they reward us
and the way that they reward us is
by releasing short chain, fatty acids
and these short chain fatty acids have healing effects
throughout the entire body so, you know,
we've been emphasizing a little bit the immune system.
Short chain fatty acids optimize our immune system.
There are studies that we could talk about if you want to
connecting short chain fatty acids
in terms of protection from respiratory viruses.
They can have their effect in the lungs
on the immune system.
Short chain fatty acids reverse leaky gut,
you know, which is, I mean, dysbiosis
that is the root cause of these digestive issues
that I take care of on a daily basis.
they directly prevent colon cancer,
they lower our cholesterol,
they prevent and reverse insulin resistance
which is type two diabetes,
they travel throughout the entire body
having their healing effects.
We think that they can actually reverse
coronary artery disease.
We think that they can actually repair
the blood brain barrier for people that have brain fog.
They actually travel into the brain
through the blood-brain barrier and they have their effects.
They affect our, our memory, they affect.
I mean, believe it or not, we have studies that suggest
that they prevent Alzheimer's disease.
These are incredibly powerful
and the way that you get them
is through the consumption of fiber in your diet
and here's the problem,
97% of Americans are not getting an adequate amount
of fiber in their diet
and that's creating issues for us.
Everybody's worried about their protein intake
but they don't give a second thought to their fiber intake.
97% of people are fiber deficient,
I mean, that's a shocking statistic.
You know and that's well, and that's with low standards,
I mean the expectation or the standard that we're holding
is 25 grams for women and 38 grams for men
and the average American is somewhere
in the 15 to 18 gram range
and you know, you see the problem exists, Rich,
When we try to do academic studies looking at fiber
and the way that we'll set the study up is we'll say,
okay, let's take the high fiber consumers
in the United States
and compare them to the low fiber consumers,
and next time you guys,
if you ever read any of these studies,
I mean, I'm a nerd, so I read these studies.
If you ever read one of these studies
take a look at the high fiber consumers,
even the high fiber consumers are deficient in fiber.
Wow.
Unlike the Hadza, which you talked about, right?
Yeah, the Hadza which is this tribe that lives in Tanzania
which is, they're fascinating because
they are modern hunters and gatherers.
They don't farm, they don't have organized agriculture.
They live off the land.
They eat whatever is available.
Yes, they eat some meat.
So, but they eat mostly plants
and these Hadza are consuming 100 grams of fiber per day
and critical piece like, Rich, let me ask you a question,
I'm just curious.
So, you, I know you eat a very healthy diet.
If you had to estimate in a given week
how many plants do you think you have in your diet?
Give me a general idea.
Yeah, I mean, you know, it's probably,
I mean, it's gonna be higher than most but
it can't be more than, I mean, 30, 40.
Okay, and I would challenge
the people listening at home right now,
like, if you have to hit the pause button,
take a minute and think about how many plants
you actually have in your diet, okay.
So, most Americans are definitely less than 30.
The majority are around 15 to 20
and the Hadza are consuming
600 varieties of plants in a given year
Right, like 600.
600 because they live off the land.
There are literally 300,000 edible plants on the planet,
the problem is that we've narrowed it down to the point
where 75% of our diet is from three of them
and we're ignoring this diversity, you know
we've put pressure unfortunately on our farmers
where the farmer has no choice
but to opt for high yield breeds of crops,
and so, we are narrowing down the bio diversity
within our diet through our food systems.
And so, with the Hadza, do they, so,
I mean, I presume that they have lower incidences
of all of these chronic ailments
as a result of this biodiverse, you know plant forward diet.
They have their challenges,
they don't live in the United States
with the healthcare system,
they don't have access to a guy like me, right,
but when we actually look at their microbiome,
what we look at is the diversity of species.
So, biodiversity is a really important word these days
and the biodiversity within your gut microbiome
is a measure of health.
The more species that you have,
the more that your gut microbiome is resistant
to sort of disturbances.
It has all the different players that are available,
you know what, they're not all the same,
they have different roles,
so, when you have that diversity
you have all the pieces that you need
no matter what you throw out your gut,
it's ready to step up and do the job.
And so, we want that biodiversity
and when we study the Hadza
and we compare their biodiversity
within their gut microbiome,
to that of a person that's say, in the UK,
we see that they have 30% more diversity
than a person in the UK,
and, you know, I hate to break it
to all the Americans who are listening right now,
but we're even worse,
they have 40% more biodiversity than we do
and the connection that's really important
for people to understand and frankly,
if there's only one thing that you take away
from this podcast listening to us
have this conversation today,
this is what I want you guys to hear, okay?
The way that it works is this,
fiber is not just fiber.
There are millions, if not billions
of types of fiber in nature.
It's so incredibly complicated from a chemistry perspective
that we're not even capable of creating an estimate
to how many types of fiber there are.
But every single plant has its own unique types of fiber,
multiple different types within that plant.
Every single plant is going to have
prebiotic fiber that feeds the microbiome.
This is their preferred food, these prebiotic fibers
and the key is that they are picky eaters.
They don't, they're like us, you know,
you have different food preferences than I do
even though I'm sure that many people would label us
as having the same diet, you eat differently than I do,
we have our own preferences
and they do too, they have specific food preferences
in terms of the different types of fiber.
To put in the perspective, take a black bean,
you give these microbes a black bean
and there are certain specific species
that are going to multiply and thrive
and they're gonna be stronger
and be more prepared to help you
because you just fed them, they were energized,
but the opposite is true.
You take that black bean away,
you say, I'm going black bean free.
Those same microbes that were thriving
because you were feeding them are starving.
Right.
And they're not getting what they need and so,
you know, Rich, this,
looking at the Hadza and comparing it to Americans
and seeing 40% more biodiversity within their microbiome,
that's interesting, that's, okay, that's cool but to me,
I wouldn't write a book based upon an idea
and that is not enough for me just to say with confidence
that the most important thing for our gut microbiome
is the diversity of plant species, I need something more
and where you find it is the American Gut Project.
The American Gut Project is the largest study to date
to take our diet and lifestyle and connect it
to the biodiversity within our gut microbiome.
It is actually an international study
even though it's called the American Gut Project.
They have people who are participating
from over 40 countries, from around the world
and there is no study more positioned
to answer this question, what is the number one predictor
of a healthy gut microbiome?
And when they analyzed this,
it was clear cut,
the number one predictor of a healthy gut microbiome
is the diversity of plants within your diet.
And so, when we set off this question,
you said, well, you're not necessarily
describing to a specific diet, well, here's why.
So, I'm vegan, you're vegan, okay, but in this study,
diversity of plants was more powerful than being vegan
because if you are vegan
and you eat the same 10 or 15 foods every single day,
you are not feeding your microbiome
and there are ulterior,
there are alternative diets that you could do,
where if you really focus on diversity of plants
within your diet, you're gonna feed your microbiome
and do a better job.
So, to me, it's not about the label that we apply,
it's about understanding the concept,
which is that it's critically important
to the health of our gut microbiome,
that we incorporate as many different varieties as possible
and in the American Gut Project,
the line that they drew in the sand
was 30 different plants per week.
Now, that doesn't mean by the way, that there's a magic
you know, difference between 30 and 29
or that 35 isn't better than 30,
the point is we want as much diversity as possible
and that's the critical piece.
Of all the places that you went for shoot,
what was your favorite episode or location?
I've only watched the first three, so.
Oh, man.
(laughs) I know
I'm under prepared.
You're gonna cry,
that last episode you're gonna cry.
Is that the one where your house burns down?
Yeah.
I cried,
both on the show and off it when I watched again but
it's hard to know 'cause they each had this own special
place, I think.
I mean, Iceland, just from a personal perspective
I wanted to just explore infinitely more.
That certainly was
and, you know, then you go to Sardinia
and you see the true village life, centuries old,
this simple way of living,
which is flying right in the face
of everything that we've grown up with,
and yet we're trying to reach back to it
to give us the gems so that we can live long.
Yeah, everybody in the village dating back 500 years
can be traced to just five families, I think, right?
Yeah and we both got to, one got cut out
but I interviewed this 100 year old lady too
and I literally could sit there all day.
The wisdom, the, just this pouring out of these people
not that they are eloquently giving you the meaning of life
but there's these simple, this
it's almost like powerful contentment
that you just don't feel from
(chuckles) anybody, it's just this,
I haven't left my village.
I have this one lady that I interviewed
that wasn't on the show, she's never been married
and I said, really, you just?
She's like, "I didn't think about it".
What do you mean you didn't think about it?
She was like, "I just was living my life
and I didn't think about it,
I didn't feel like I needed a man
and so, it just never happened."
And I was like, "wow!"
Like she didn't buy into anything
because their village was also not impressed upon
these made up ideologies.
It was, this is the simple way of living,
I'm content in such a degree, I'm blowing apart
things that we think we need to accomplish.
Yeah and what is the half-life on those experiences
right, like you've had many of these
over the course of your life but then you come home,
how much of that sits with you
and changes how you live on a daily basis versus,
you know, fading away?
Like, that's the trick, right?
You go in you're like, we got it all wrong,
look at what these people are doing
and then we go back and then we just do what we always do.
Yeah.
Yeah, I think that's a great point, I mean, largely I've,
I mean, you know, I'm pretty,
I'm pretty content in my now year
that I had to construct after the fire and on the land and
under the trees, so, on one respect,
all and every trip that I've taken
has influenced me into the kind of life that I want.
Now, at the same time, I am pulled
and drawn to contribute
and leave something behind whether it's education,
inspiration, connecting things
and making certain things possible to contribute to
things that I think we need to on a bigger scale,
whether that's health, whether that's the environment,
that's the wrestle,
so, I have a huge desire to contribute in that way.
That's, I wouldn't say I'm content with that,
because it's driving me,
but I'm content in
saying yes to it.
It fuels me through, you know, going back to like,
the population of people loving the show,
I look at it as like, yes, keep coming,
keep coming to what I'm doing, keep coming.
There are things that I'm creating
that I can't reveal yet, but I am not stopping
and I'm not okay with sitting in Swale or in Sardinia
becoming a hundred years old.
Right, that's not gonna work for you.
No.
That's not your blueprint anyway.
That's not my blueprint of the,
(both laughing)
the blue zones,
but I think that's also the contentment of finding you,
finding me, finding what drives me,
not from an ego perspective, but from
the heart of, you know,
the heart of everything I wanna do
and it really comes down to two very simple things.
I care about the health of people,
I believe a healthy person has more choices
and can really kick ass in their life
and not have to drag around this body
and then be kind of this victim of a body that's failing.
So, I believe in health of the individual,
mentally, emotionally, physically, spiritually,
and I believe in the intimate connection
in the health of the planet,
so, if we can contribute in those ways,
anything else, you know me, anything else I just don't care.
Well, I can't let you go without leaving,
leaving people with a couple of things
that they can take with them.
The show did such a great job of talking about
a lot of the stuff that you care about
in a very macro sense, like we go to Iceland
and we see how they're generating sustainable power
but it's like, all right, well, what can I do?
You know, what am I, how do I translate that
into something actionable in my day-to-day life?
So, I think, you know, it would be great
through the lens of sustainability and personal health
to leave people with a couple
simple practices that they could think about
and perhaps integrate into their lives that would help them.
Well, I think that's more clear,
thank you and I think more clear than ever,
people need to be healthy.
They need to stop distracting themselves and eat more plants
and figure out a program that's gonna work and get healthy
because we need strong people to do that.
Gimme a little vegan bicep flex right now.
(Darin laughs)
There you go, come on.
Dude (laughs).
Yeah, so.
So, we need strong, healthy, happy people,
non-judgmentally kicking ass in their life
and I really believe that's the purpose of health,
so that you can kick ass in your life
and have the fulfilling life you want
so you're not miserable
with a chemistry set that isn't working.
So, find a different way if it's,
you know, your app, if it's my app, the 121 Tribe,
if it's finding a group of people even online or whatever,
that you can move and explore and just, you know
find recipes that work, eat better, hydrate yourself,
without a doubt,
that's the easiest one I think environmentally
and it may feel like people have heard this before,
but single use plastic, my God, we need to stop,
quit buying, you know, cartons and containers
and water bottles that you're literally just using
and throwing away.
Unless you have a technology that you're able to
use paralysis and break down the plastic
and turning it into fuel for your Tesla,
which actually exists,
so, I'm mentioning it for a reason,
unless you have that technology,
stop using the single use plastic,
do everything you can
and this goes hand in hand to that is,
start being aware of the unsustainable business practices
of companies and big companies and support
and maybe pay a little extra money for your food,
for your conveniences,
to support companies that are doing things right.
Supporting companies that are being transparent
with what they're doing and what they're offering
and that is absolutely something you can do right now
and demand that, support those small,
of course, right now, support the small businesses right now
and if anything, I know so many more from,
all of them reaching out from the show
that there is great people
doing incredible things that people don't know about.
So, look at your dental floss,
that Glide dental floss that is creating,
putting toxins in your liver
by these chemicals of a PGA's and all of this other,
stop using that company
because that company doesn't give a shit about you,
use a bamboo string or whatever,
like, that's literally what I'm saying.
Stop the toxic exposure to yourself and your life
and support companies
that are actually giving a shit about you,
I think those are a lot of things that we can do to
put attention on what needs attention
and stop putting your hard earned money and attention
on companies that don't care and have never cared.
Walk me through the experience of this journey
that you see with the typical patient,
I mean, you're demanding a lot of them
that are going through something they've never done before,
like, what is the, you know,
what is that like for that individual
when they're on day three, day 10, day 30?
Yeah, so, the first few days of fasting
are actually the most difficult
because you're adapting
off of glucose metabolism into fat metabolism,
so, the brain is changing fuels
from burning sugar to burning largely
beta hydroxybutyric acid
which comes from the ketone bodies from the fat breakdown,
so, there's an adjustment there,
you're detoxing, oftentimes a lot.
Although we've learned to minimize
the effective detoxification
by getting people to eat a fruit vegetable only diet
for a few days before we start fasting,
that's made a huge difference,
so, they're not coming off caffeine addiction
at the same moment that they're trying to adapt to the fast,
they've already gotten that stuff out of their system
and that's actually the most difficult stuff,
forgetting the cigarettes, the caffeine, alcohol
all that meat, fish, fowl, eggs,
dairy products, processed foods,
all the host of chemicals
that people are putting into their body with
over the counter prescription medications.
So, we've gone through a wind-down process
and then we start fasting and their mouth might coat up
and tastes like something crawled in there and died
and they may have some skin rashes or elimination,
they may get mucus discharge,
they may get some vivid dreams,
they may have aches and pains
and they may have difficulties with
all kinds of adaptive process, but they go away,
and then something else comes along and then it goes away
and then it becomes very empowering
because they realize that
they're able to get through this process.
That just because they had a headache
doesn't mean they have to rush out
and try to suppress those symptoms with a pill,
it goes away, the body's able to heal itself.
And then once you get into four or five days of fasting,
the body's pretty well acclimated to the fasting.
Again, at this point, there's no hunger.
People are going to cooking demonstrations,
they're coming to lectures,
they're going to the dining room to socialize with people,
there are five days, 10 days into a fast,
you think, oh, my God, you haven't eaten for 10 days?
No, they just enjoyed being there,
it's not a problem.
That's crazy.
So then, depending on the patient,
sometimes they start getting relief,
their pain, maybe for the first time in years
the pain that they've been suffering with is going away
and they may find that, you know,
some people that have these chronic debilitating problems
start resolving, things start falling off,
tumor starts shrinking, they start getting excited like, Oh,
maybe there's something to this idea
of the body healing itself,
and you know, we're monitoring these patients
to go through the process and then at some point,
you get to the point where there's a limiting factor,
maybe their electrolytes start to drop a little bit
or their energy is not acceptable,
they're not able to maintain accurate ambulation
or maybe they've just, that's how much time they've got
'cause you know, some people have jobs and lives
and responsibilities, so, we only have so much...
Here for 40 days.
All my life completely craters on the outside.
But for many people,
this is an intense epiphanic experience
because they've got this intense education
that they're really open to.
They've seen these other people,
sometimes what looks to them like miracles going on,
'cause they're seeing people that
they have no expectation that that could get well
getting well,
they're experiencing themselves sometimes for the first time
you know, a sense of empowerment
because they're able to actually reverse these processes
that there were told nothing could be done,
learn to live with it,
what do they expect at their age?
That's just how it is.
And now they're thinking, wow,
if they were wrong about that,
maybe they're wrong about other things too
and you start looking at all aspects of their life.
The empowerment aspect of it is gotta be huge.
Like, even if you set aside all of these,
you know, physical benefits that are a result of this,
simply, the fact that they did something
that seems impossible, very very difficult
and get to the other side of it
has to, you know, sort of
make them feel like, okay, now nothing is impossible,
like, I just did this thing that almost nobody does,
now, what's the next challenge that I can tackle?
You know, the idea is that many people think that
if you fast, you die.
They believe if they got on a plane in New York
and they were to fly all the way to California,
they would die over Colorado, except the ate the peanuts.
You know, that the Pretzels saved their life.
What do you eat when you fly?
And somehow if you fasted for 10 days or 20 days,
sometimes the idea that you might have to skip a meal
'cause there was nothing to healthy eat,
it doesn't seem quite so overwhelming.
There was definitely empowerment.
And I think that the other thing that happens is
when you start feeling what it feels like to be you
instead of what you'd become, that's for apparent,
I think the same thing happens to athletes.
When people first start exercising at first,
it's not pleasant, they got aches, they got pains,
they're fatigued, they're not getting the success,
they can't do what they want, but as they do it,
they get to the point where not only do they tolerate
they're not just doing it 'cause they wanna, you know
maintain the weight or get the figure or whatever it is,
they're doing 'cause they start realizing
they're getting real intrinsic benefit
from engaging in this consistent activity
and now they don't wanna give it up,
and I think the same thing happens
when people really get into a healthy lifestyle.
Yeah, they're invested.
They don't wanna go
give it up and feel like everybody else feels
because of some greasy, slimy, convenient food,
they're willing to pay the price of trying to
do the planning and do what it takes to try to ensure
that they can get their needs met.
Just like I think people that get
into a regular exercise regime,
realize that now this is so beneficial,
they will literally structure their schedules around
making sure that that's an important part of their activity
and the same thing happens with sleep.
When you realize how important sleep is to health
and maintenance and energy, you start prioritizing that
and you don't compromise your sleep,
you don't compromise your exercise
and hopefully you don't,
you learn to not compromise your diet and lifestyle.
I tell people, here's what you need to do,
first, get enough sleep
'cause it's your most critical activity,
then engage in regular exercise
so you can dissipate the tension, you can build fitness
and have the time to prepare and eat healthy food,
if there happens to be any time left,
we'll fine, you got to work.
(Rich laughs)
And so, what we're encouraging people to do
is a really radical departure
from what they're currently doing,
but that's to adopt a whole plant food diet
that's free of this added chemicals,
free of the salt, oil and sugar,
and what you're left with
is things like fruits and vegetables, raw or cooked.
Minimally processed, grains, beans, nuts and seeds
but you don't have the meat, fish, Val, eggs,
dairy products, oil, salt, sugar
and highly processed fractionated foods
that make up the majority of the people's diet
in industrialized society,
and it's that diet that makes them fat and sick
and develop the disease of dietary excess
and that what's makes you vulnerable to infectious disease.
You know, when you look at what are the vulnerabilities
about why do some people get an influenza or a COVID
or an infectious disease and, you know, they recover,
they survive, they have minimal consequences,
other people it's devastating or deadly.
Well, if you look at the risk factors
associated with what makes people vulnerable
to these diseases as well as the disease,
the chronic diseases, heart disease, the cancer, the stroke,
it's the same metabolic syndrome
and all of its associations,
it's the same obesity and diabetes and high blood pressure
and all the consequences of dietary excess.
These are reversible and preventable conditions.
People don't have to have these conditions
and even if they have them, they can largely reverse them
by taking responsibility
to control what they put in their mouth.
We have a little bit of a show and tell here,
if you're watching this on video
you can see like all this plant-based cheese here
but before we even get into the latest with SriMu,
I think one thing that gets lost in your story
as somebody who's been on this podcast a million times
and is always sharing, you know, deep thoughts
and you know, the spiritual practices
is the fact that and you alluded to it a minute ago,
the fact that
you're like this serial entrepreneur and always have been
like, you're a business, a powerful business woman, like
setting aside SriMu which we're gonna get into.
I mean, you had, you know,
this garment line for years and years and years,
like pre-internet where you were doing
direct to consumer before it was a thing
and you have this robust interior design business,
like you've had a lot of chapters in your business career
that have delivered you to this place to, you know,
create this new venture that you're working on right now.
So, I thought it would be cool to
share that side of you a little bit, because that,
I don't know that we've really fully
explored that on the podcast.
Yeah, cool, thanks for that.
It's kind of interesting to hear you describe me like that,
thank you so much, I receive that.
You're a startup founder.
I kind of I'm,
no, I actually I'm.
You've had multiple startups
like there's a whole career, decades of
experience that you garnered
doing difficult things in the business world
and succeeding and failing and trying again,
so, when you look back,
when you reflect on those experiences, you know,
what did you learn that has informed your approach to
you know, SriMu and what you're doing now?
Well, I mean, I think what I've learned is that,
you know, in order to create something that's very powerful,
the vision has to be very unified,
like very, very true and very, very real.
So, I knew when I was creating SriMu,
it was sort of had to be this expression of
beautiful design, highest quality, purest ingredients
and really done in the way where it's,
I consider SriMu to be a beauty brand,
we haven't seen it, there's more gonna be coming,
cheese is leading, but it's really a beauty brand,
I'm offering SriMu as an invitation to a beautiful life
and that beautiful life comes from
eating a high vibrational, not cheese product
which I call the next evolution of cheese,
so, I'm not asking us to give up our love of cheese,
I've just made it better.
So, it's better for our health, our bodies,
it's better for the animals, it's better for the planet
and it's ultimately better for our children.
And so, for me, you know, meeting Brian O'Hara
who is the amazing artist who did this coding
which I have these tattoos go out with SriMu shipments,
and this coding, Brian has written backwards
and read backwards his entire life
and so, he developed this branding for me,
this says devotional offering,
this is what is within this coding
and it's part of my label and my brand
and so, I guess for me, it's like I had to start
at the peak of the artistic expression
knowing that this is a global brand
and I have over 40 recipes of cheese
where I can tell you anyone that ate them would be, you know
falling on the floor in ecstasy
or being very excited about the flavors,
but SriMu now is at the top of that and then, you know,
as I go, there will be more mass products and, you know
there's many more aspects of the business and the vision.
So, perhaps I'm overestimating
how aware of the audience is about
what you are doing at the moment,
it probably is worth providing a little bit of background.
So, you co-authored a couple of cookbooks with me
which were really your cookbooks,
like, my name is on them.
Let's just be honest.
If we're being honest, like you,
in solidarity with my decision to go plant-based
and train for these races, you showed up and
infused our kitchen
with a tremendous amount of creativity to,
initially to support me,
but then it became it's own creative inspiration for you.
The result of that is
everything that we've co-created together including
the "Plant Power Way" cookbook
the "Plant Power Way" Italia cookbook,
which is a nod to the retreats that we do,
where we take these groups of people to this beautiful
agriturismo in Tuscany and have a seven day experience of
food and meditation and community,
and in addition to that,
you authored another book called "This Cheese is Nuts".
You became obsessed with trying to figure out
how to create plant-based cheese
and this was many years ago, this wasn't yesterday
and you basically went into the kitchen,
treated it like a lab and set about
cracking the code on trying to create
like the next evolution,
the next level of what a plant-based cheese could taste like
because at the time,
there were plenty of brands in the store,
most of them not so good,
most of them taste kind of the same, relatively bland and
you thought there's gotta be a better way to do this,
and over many years and a lot of experimentation
you really figured it out.
I have to say like, you completely figured it out
and you created this book, which basically tells people
how to do this themselves at home,
you continue to iterate and learn and experiment and grow
and then it got to this place where people were like,
well, I love the book, but you know,
I'm just never gonna do this at home.
Like, can you just make, 'cause you would make it
and we would bring it to dinner parties
or we would share it with friends
and people would just flip out,
like they would just lose their minds.
They just couldn't believe that
there wasn't dairy in this cheese 'cause this isn't just,
this isn't like American slices of cheese, this is
like, high-end very fine artismal wheels of cheese
that are reminiscent of, you know,
the Parisian flavors that you're so familiar with
whether it's a Brie or a Camembert or you know,
those kinds of exotic, very cheesy iterations of cheese.
And people would say like, just, can you just make,
like, I'll buy it, like, I'm never gonna,
I'm too busy I'm not gonna make this, will you just make it?
And you were like, I'm not gonna do that but then, you know,
it dawned on you at some point,
I'm interested in what that point was,
where you just decided, okay, maybe I can do this
and so, you said about like,
creating this line of cheese called SriMu
which is now a full-fledged startup.
We're gonna get into what's happening currently with it
but you've turned it into
this really beautiful direct to consumer product line.
Super proud of you.
Yeah, so, well, it took.
Yeah, thanks, I mean, it took.
First of all, I mean, I have
friends of mine that live in Paris half the time,
Lucien Jan Welters
and he's a fashion photographer, she's a stylist and,
you know, they eat French cheese,
like they speak French, their kids speak French,
like they live in Paris half the time
and they were freaking out over my cheese.
So, they would just be, you know, inhaling it saying,
"You have to make this, you have to make this," and,
you know, I took a long time.
I have to say I had a lot of pain over what I attempted
or what I experienced with Julie Piatt Collection
and I was like, I know what production is,
I'm not at a loss at what that is,
and I started to sort of meditate on what it would take
to launch this food company and quite frankly,
it's a lot simpler, it's a lot more direct,
and it has a greater capacity to make a global impact
that will be a legacy for me.
I mean, something that would actually
transform people's lives from within their kitchens.
And I've done that with my cookbooks and, you know,
I know that food is an energy, recipes are an energy
and I believe that when I infuse these recipes with my
love of source connection,
that this somehow makes it into whoever is eating the food.
And so, with SriMu, the vision was to make a beautiful brand
that was crafted in devotion with the best ingredients
and was made with the purest intentions.
So, truly, truly made
for the purpose of supporting animals,
supporting creating more love on the earth,
supporting our bodies.
I'm a very, I have a very sensitive stomach,
I can't eat dairy, I can't eat a handful of nuts.
I mean, I can eat dairy, but I have a stomachache after
so, let's be clear,
you know, before, when I wasn't vegan,
but even if I eat a handful of nuts
I have a stomachache right away.
So, working with these cheeses and curing them
and soaking them and adding the cultures and processing them
I never had a stomach ache any of the time
and I was absolutely stunned at the
quality of cheese experience that I've been able to create
and the reason I think that I was able to create it
is that I literally worked on my own
in an experience of exploration
and I just went for it and tried things.
There were a lot of fails before I figured it out but
I've really figured it out.
Yeah, well, a couple things, the first thing is
there were a lot of people who said,
well, why don't you just go to the farmer's market
and set up your booth and like sell it
and you're like, I'm not doing that.
Like, I did a version of that when I had my fashion line,
I'm not interested in that,
I'm only interested in creating something that I can scale,
and secondarily,
there's this idea when you raise the issue
of like a plant-based cheese, people immediately think
fake cheese and their mind turns to all these
processed chemicals that
a lot of these companies use as binders to
create the flavor and the texture
that people are used to with cheese, right
and that's like a hurdle that you've had to
address and overcome because there is none of that
in what you do.
I mean, there's actually very few ingredients
in this product.
Yeah, they're very pure.
This is not a gooey, creepy, vegan cheese
that tastes horrible that you wanna gag,
it's very pure and authentic and I think if I,
you know, what I've learned as a designer,
you know, you asked, what did you learn?
Well, I think what we learn as designers or painters
or fashion designers or writers,
is you get to a level of maturity
where you understand that less is more,
in fact, it's the simplicity
that makes something extraordinary.
And so, if my recipes stand for anything,
they stand for the ability to be simply
showcasing what mother nature provides
with some alchemy and design and flair and, you know,
and definitely taste,
but it's really in the simplicity of what is done
and trying to preserve purity in the product.
Look, man, I'm really delighted to meet you,
I've been a fan for a long time,
have so much respect for your work, not just your work
but like how you live your life, how you comport yourself.
I'm excited to unpack all of it
with you today, man.
Yeah, me too.
And I've also said this before with people who have,
you know, a social media presence,
there is that sense that you feel like you know somebody,
I definitely have that with you, but it's different.
I do feel like a level of connectedness to you that I
don't have with other people, even though we've never met
and I think that speaks to
what I think is your greatest talent,
which is that you're a storyteller
you're always telling stories and you do it in a way
that is really brings people into your experiences
and makes them feel like they're right alongside with you.
That means a lot, I mean, that's really the goal.
If there's a way to compromise this entire life story
into one sentence, it's that,
I really wanna tell meaningful stories
and it's a funny thing not to dive straight in but
that started with just my immediate family,
my mom, my dad, right,
and then evolved now to millions of people,
but the reality is like the,
I think the effort and the intimacy is the same.
Like, I oftentimes, you know,
can be at fault for wanting to share too much
because I just really enjoy bringing people
into what that experience is like,
and being honest and real
as much as you can in this day and age.
Well, there's a tension there because
everything you're about is about being present in the moment
and really immersing yourself
in the environments that you're in,
but to share that is to take you out of that experience,
right?
Right.
So, how do you like wrestle with that
aspect of what you do?
That's so hard, there's boundaries
that I think life creates
just in general with how we,
how much we can share, how much it's available to people,
and then you have this whole, you know, kind of
I think issue nowadays
of like the relate-ability and people understanding you
and everything's gotta be so like, you know
synthesized down to like very straightforward
terms and how you say it
because you don't wanna offend anybody nowadays
but there's a rawness and a realness to, I think
bring people out on the road
and bringing people with me into those experiences
and I think if anything, I've really relied upon (laughs)
my wife as a guiding source of that
and also, I think just understanding that, you know
and this is a funny thing 'cause I,
to be honest, I kinda hate talking about social media
in many ways.
I've always seen it, but I also love it, right,
so, I've always seen it as all it is
is a glorified texting platform
and you have this beautiful opportunity
to get to know the people that you're communicating with.
You know, it's not this thing where you're just
opening the door to someone's house, blurting out a message,
then before they have the chance to come to the door
you just close it, right?
Like, there's this reciprocation so,
I feel more than maybe most,
really tuned into like the needs, the questions, the ideas
what they wanna see and then
a lot of times that can in many ways direct
almost like the projects, the stories,
the things I wanna tell.
I can adhere to the needs of young parents
because I'm a young parent and it's a scary thing
and it terrifies me every day and then making films
or books or whatever that can address these things
or addressing climate or environmental issues,
but through my lens, I guess, kind of to
get back to the core of that question, I feel like
learning to listen to what the needs of this audience is
because that's really who you're serving, right?
Like as a person who's putting work into the world,
you're trying to serve a broad group of people
and obviously you can't do it perfectly
but you're trying to kind of tune into those
who really understand you.
You know, to your point about social media,
I mean, you're a guy who,
you've got, like, I don't know,
4 million people on Instagram who follow you,
which is insane, right
and that has to induce some level of vertigo, right?
Like, how do I manage this?
And how do I,
you know, shoulder the responsibility of communicating
at such a mass level
and in trying to deconstruct like how you got to this place
where so many people are interested in experiencing,
you know, life through your lens,
there's a lot of really technically talented
nature and adventure photographers out there
who are doing amazing things,
so, why is it that you have 4 million
and somebody else who's, you know,
perhaps equally technically skilled has
a middling size audience and
the only answer that I can come up with
is really your super power, which is this capacity
for bringing people along and the story,
the humanizing storytelling aspect of it by, you know
capturing these austere environments
and translating the meaning of that through, you know
your emotional landscape in a way that connects with people
that makes them feel like, you know
as I said at the outset, like I feel connected to you
because of your ability to storytell in that way.
And that means a lot, I appreciate that
and I would just say that with that, like I aim,
I've realized early on in my career that
I really pride myself on trying to document
experiences, sports, places, locations,
that felt approachable, that felt accessible
and yeah, occasionally I'll shoot somebody
highlining through an eclipse or a moon
or something just off, you know, crazy
but for the most part like, I'm just, you know,
five-eight short dude with no athletic background
who gave the time and commitment to something and did it
and I want people to realize that, absolutely,
I am not the most technically sound photographer,
absolutely, I'm not the most creative,
I'm just the person stupid enough
to commit themselves to something enough to see it through
and I think that's always been my strength
and that's always been my goal
and I want others to understand
that if they come from an impoverished situation
or they come from an unlikely situation
and if they're willing to work for it, they can get,
they can be in the situation
and I think that's kind of been
something I've prided myself on
is trying to tell stories that feel approachable,
trying to tell stories that feel real
and with this bike ride again, it's like that's a real
and or approachable story that people can relate to
and whether they wanna be in that situation
or they just wanna route along the sidelines,
like that's a really
awesome experience to share with somebody,
the vulnerability of how we present ourselves online is
I think, so important for
people to understand and relate to
and I've really tried to put emphasis on what I say
as much as what I share visually.
That being said, you know, we're in this day and age where
it's so easy to just
strip some beautiful quote off the internet
or tell people that
the mountains are calling and they must go
and really that means nothing, like,
this is the place you make your own quotes,
the books, the films, the social media,
whatever, what have you,
this is the place where you tell people what it
felt like to be there because to be honest,
you only do people a disservice
by describing what they can see in the photo.
You have eyes, this is a visual platform,
you have to engage with it visually,
I don't need to tell people that it's cold
and the person's surfing in cold water
and there's mountains and guess what?
We're in Norway.
I need to tell you the visceral experience
of what it felt like to be there
because that's all I can offer.
'Cause as a photographer, as a storyteller,
what does it feel like
for the snow to hit the back of my neck?
What did it feel like to
feel the crunch of it under my feet?
What did it feel like to push the trigger of the camera?
What did it feel like to, you know
to document this moment and why?
And so, I think that in many ways
those are the questions I'm seeking
and whenever I'm doing any, like,
again, whether it's taking a picture,
whether it's making a film or speaking or riding a bike,
like I wanna share those things
because that's I think what people connect to.
I wanna talk about water
and your relationship to water and the ocean,
like, I'm in certain respects a different kind of water man,
I'm a swimmer, I grew up swimming, swimming is my passion
and it started in pools and, you know,
I've done interesting things in the water
like monofin swimming, things like that
and now it's about ocean swimming
and then I got into ultra endurance triathlon and all that
but I have a very
deep and emotional connection
to the experience of being in water and underwater
that's overlaps with yours a little bit, I would suppose so,
I'm interested in how you
think about your relationship to the ocean and you know,
how you articulate, like what that means.
First of all, that's my Grandmaster, right?
Like if you said, who's your, you know,
people say, Hey, who do you look up to
or who do you, you know, who influenced you?
I mean, I'd have to say that the ocean probably
has had the biggest impact on shaping the way I behave
more than any one person,
except maybe my mom, because she birthed me and
she had a huge influence of course, but the ocean,
the lessons that you learned from the ocean
the relationship that you have with it,
it just, it covers so many things and I know that, you know,
my reverence for the ocean, just
my reverence for its power, its beauty, you know,
its magnitude, like it's just the massiveness of it
and insignificant, it's our space, right?
Like the ocean is our space on earth.
Like, if you wanna know what space is like,
you just go to the ocean and that will tell you what,
you can go to the edge of the space
or you can go deep into space
and it's been, it was a great escape for me when I was a kid
to leave kind of
the cares of the land behind you
and all the worries and all the stresses.
When you're under water, all of that gets muted,
right and it's just between you and the elements.
Yeah and maybe just a giant
shark that may be lurking in the distance.
(both laughing)
There was always that in the back of your head, like,
hmm, let me see, I'm not a big fan
of swimming out in the middle of the ocean
with a mask that you can't see very well but (laughs).
Yeah.
But the,
but, you know, so I think I,
so, the relationship with the animals in the ocean,
with the weight, just with the,
with how it makes you feel,
like the therapy of the heat, it heals you.
It's being back in the womb.
It is, yeah.
You know.
And you get healed from it,
like you can go and be in the water and you know,
now we get all these science, you know, science follows
I say, science follows instinct, but you know,
you have these ideas like, hey, this really,
like I go there and I feel different, everything's different
then they get some data in there, so, like, yeah
that's 'cause you're getting negative ions
in the thing and you're grounding
and your compression and all this stuff, but.
Andrew Huberman shows that validates what you've
been telling yourself for 20 years.
No, it's true, it's true.
Yeah.
And that's kind of, I mean, that's
pretty amazing that in this time, you know,
in world, that we can do that,
that we're getting to do that,
but it seems like your instincts
you know, your gut instincts and your intuitions
and all those things,
those serve you right and I think there's a karmic thing.
I mean, obviously the ocean is the most conductive
element on earth,
and so, you know, sound travels through it, waves,
sound waves, but also wave energy, what we ride, so,
and I know like karmically, you know
whenever I'm in the ocean and I have some negative thoughts
or some feelings or something,
I usually just pay instantaneously.
I crash, the wave comes and hits me and I'm like,
oh, yeah, that's right, I was supposed to,
I gotta shed that stuff,
I gotta clear my mind.
Again, like a deeper level of humility,
I mean, there's this idea that
you're conquering these waves,
You're not conquering these waves, you're trying to,
you're trying to exist in symbiosis with them.
Harmonious, that's why I always talk about the harmony,
riding a wave
is an act of harmony.
You're trying to be harmonious with it.
You don't conquer waves, you have the fortune
to ride them for a moment and be part of them and
you know, if everything goes right,
but yeah, you don't, there's no conquering the ocean.
No, you know, my sense is that
it gives you this deep appreciation
for the natural world, right?
Like, I had Alex Honnold on here, I've had Kilian Jornet
and like the themes, you know,
it's just this, like, the majesty of nature
is just so profound when you're
in the midst of trying to do your thing.
Yeah.
In harmony with that harsh natural environment
where the stakes are very high.
Be observant, you know, being observant, I think that's
even today, like I was at my house and there was some hawks
that fly by my house and just,
and they come and you know and the more aware you are,
it seems the more connected you become to it
and all of a sudden, it's almost like they come over
and say hi to you and you're like, hey, how's it going?
They go, (cawing) and they turn away
and I mean, you could go yeah, okay, the hawk, but
did the hawk, I mean, you're connecting with the hawk.
The hawk came and
but you have to be observant to even see the hawk,
then you have to actually put the energy and the thoughts
to the Hawk in a way that you, that you're,
how you're observing it and what you're,
what it means to you and that happens with the dolphins,
that happens with the, you know, the whale,
that happens with all the creatures of creation
and ultimately nature.
I mean, nature is just, I mean, it's
it is creation, right?
So, we talk about creation, the great creation,
we'll nature's creation
so you get to observe it
and I think being aware of it
being aware of the sunrise
and the sunset and the movement and all that stuff,
connecting to it
allows you a deeper relationship with it.
'Cause you can't have this deep relationship
without having the observation and being aware
of all these things, as you become,
the more aware you become,
the deeper that relationships become
and then the more it shows itself to you.
It's like people talk about going on these
journeys and reconnecting with nature and I'm like,
if you're already reconnected, if you're already connected
then that's not gonna be so profound,
it's just that so many of us have grown so far away from,
Hey, it's hot, I'll turn the AC on,
Hey, it's cold, turn the chill on.
Hey, it's dark switch the lights on, hey, you know,
it's bright put the shades on, it's like, we're just
we're insulating ourselves from it and, you know,
and obviously the ocean is the is the king
because it's alive and moving
and has, I mean all the things it can do
just freezing and liquid and steam
and just to, I mean, it's like
the unexpressable element, it's just has too many.
And still so mysterious.
Mysterious, mysterious.
But on the on the hawk example,
I mean, think that the hawk example to me
is an illustration of the fact that
no matter where you are, you're still in nature.
Like we have this bifurcated, like, idea, like,
right now we're not in nature.
Like, we need to go down to Point Dume to be in nature
but we're in nature right now.
Oh, absolutely.
We are always in nature
and we always have that opportunity
to be more connected to the environment and the energy
and everything that's going on,
if we can be still and observant.
Oh, man, I think that that's one of the things that
will help everyone, will help humanity the most
is if we can continue to we, 'cause we have it, right,
we have an ability to really
be connected to nature in a way that we don't,
is so profound we don't even fully understand it.
The depth of what we're capable of and what we
and the depth of that relationship
'cause, you know, I always, we are it and it is us.
I mean, we're so con, you know,
if you think you're not connected to the sun,
if you think you're not connected to, you know,
everything and you're not
and it's not you and you're not it, then that's, you know,
and that's the big separation right now
and it seems that in the present
that we've been, we've become so insulated
that that's what's leading to people being
either depressed or having physical ailments
or whatever it is, a lot of it
is 'cause they're not fulfilling,
I believe they're not fulfilling, you know, this void
which is what nature was fulfilling.
Like nature was filling this void in them
through just even observation, even just looking
and connecting that way, it's filling this,
and then all of a sudden you have this void
and then you're just putting stuff in it that the body
you know, and the soul and everything can't connect to.
Probably not a lot of, not an epidemic
of anxiety and depression
and you know, indigenous tribes that are
dealing with survival and connected fundamentally
to the world in which they live.
You know what I mean?
None, there would be none.
No allergies either.
No allergies either (laughs).
But then on top of that,
on top of that, to engage in, you know,
the high risk kind of adventures that light you up
gives you, you know, it puts you
in this contact with the fragility of life
or what death means
that I think enlivens your daily experience, right?
Like, how do you think about risk and death?
Well, I mean, first of all I think
that's the most honest way you can live.
The most honest way you can live is
to know that dying is very easy and you can die any minute,
and then how would you conduct yourself?
You know what I mean?
And I think for me, that's a daily challenge
and a weekly challenge and a monthly challenge
and a yearly challenge is just
to always have that kind of awareness that
death is ever present and the truth is that,
the truth is that right now, death has a name
and it's walking around and people are,
it's affecting people severely because they,
because their relationship with death is so insulated
through just the way life has become that it's,
we're not living honestly like we would
if we were out in nature being
threatened constantly by stuff then we'd be,
our awareness would be so heightened.
But, you know, I feel that
you don't know what being truly alive is unless
without that relationship to that edge, you know,
to knowing where that edge is,
like when you're a kid like, He, where's this place,
where do you fall off?
It's just a big,
if you take the evolution of what's dangerous
when you're a little kid and you grow into a mature adult,
then you go, okay, well, that's the same relationship,
it's just that everything has become,
the scales have become bigger
but it's still honest, it's just so honest.
I woke up one day or a series of days and
didn't really think that my future
was gonna be better than my past
and that's a really scary place to be at.
I think that leads to a lot of mental health issues and
devastating situations for people.
And it wasn't that I didn't like my life or my situation
or my business or I did,
wasn't proud of what we accomplished at Tom's,
but I realized that if we, anyone
and me specific in this situation, if we are
looking to external accomplishments, external praise,
anything, anything even your kids' love
for your sense of peace and joy,
ultimately, you will realize that it doesn't work
and that is a really scary place to land
and that's where I landed.
I had accomplished everything,
I'd been on the covers of every magazine I'd helped,
you know, at that point 80 million children get shoes,
I had made hundreds of millions of dollars, I mean,
I literally had kids, I had everything that
I possibly could have been told was the key to
not just a happy life, but actually a meaningful life,
you know, it wasn't like, I, you know
just chased after like these hedonistic pleasures.
And it wasn't just a company
that was profit above everything else,
like there's such a built-in massive service aspect
to what you were doing,
what you would think would buffer you against that.
But I think in some ways it made it worse because.
Well, the guilt and the shame of feeling that way.
That but also there was nowhere to go.
So, if you think about it,
if you had a traditional businessman or woman
and they built a huge company, made a bunch of money,
how has and they realized,
it's really not what it's cracked up to be.
Now I can be a philanthropist.
The next 20 years doing that but I'd already done that
and I realized it wasn't better than, you know, and so.
So, I reached a point where, and there's
this amazing teacher who I love named Sadhguru,
I don't know if you know Sadhguru,
but we got to spend some time together,
we have a very shared passion for golf
and we've golfed together
and he's stayed at my house in Wyoming.
And he said in the, in the Yoga Sutras,
there's this one book and I forget which one it is,
but the very first line is
and now yoga and what that meant to him as he explained
'cause he knows quite a bit about my life story is
that moment was when my yoga really started.
It was I had to accomplish all those things,
I had to do all of that in my life to realize
the joy and the peace
and the sense of connection to the great mystery
that I've been searching for,
would never be found in those external things
and that's when I could start my yoga practice.
Yeah, to reframe it as an opportunity,
but ultimately to have to
basically, experience all of that on the grandness level
in order to understand fully that it isn't the solution,
right, 'cause anybody who's listening or watching,
myself included, yeah, there's a little bit of that
but there's also like,
yeah, maybe he says that, but you know
that's not gonna be the way it is for me, right
and it's like, it doesn't matter how many successful people
sit across from me and tell me
their version of that exact same story,
it always holds true, right?
And yet it's so difficult to wrap the human mind around that
like how could that possibly be true?
Because it's so contrary
to everything that we've been hardwired to believe
since as long as we can remember.
Totally, I mean, I actually had a very
prophetic conversation where
I was told this was gonna happen
and it was by Ted Turner.
So, I looked up to Ted Turner a lot as an entrepreneur,
as I said, I read every biography
and there's a few great winds on Ted Turner
and Ted Turner had some similarities with me, you know,
he started an outdoor advertising company
before starting CNN, started the network.
I lived on a sailboat for six years,
Ted Turner's a huge sailor, one of America's corp.
Started a cable TV channel.
Started CNN.
So, I was asked to interview Ted Turner
maybe seven or eight years ago at the UN
and I got to spend the morning with Ted Turner
and he was real hero to me,
so, like this was a really special experience and
so, I spent, you know,
just months preparing for this interview
and read every book again
and it was really excited to do this interview with Ted.
And so,
but right before we went on stage,
we're having this conversation
and Ted said to me, he said, you know
we're talking about life and he said, you know,
in life and in business,
especially in business, you know, it's like this ladder
and it's not like the corporate ladder, like you're about
but it's like this ladder of like
believing that if you climb up this ladder,
that at the top, there's something magical
and something that's going to
give you everything that you've ever wanted
and as you start to climb the ladder
you see this beautiful bag on the top of the ladder
and you can only think what's in the bag
when you get to the top
and he said, I spent so much of my life climbing that ladder
to get a peek into that bag,
and he says and I've seen inside the bag,
and of course at this age, I was like, maybe
I don't know, I was 38, 40 years old, I said,
what's in the bag?
And he goes, "I'll tell you, what's in the bag,
the bag is empty and even though I've told you,
you still need to climb the ladder and look for yourself."
(Rich laughs)
He knows well enough to know that
just him telling you that ain't gonna do it.
And I'll never forget that conversation with Ted,
I mean, it was one of the most beautiful life,
like when we watch the movie of our lives,
it'll definitely be in the highlight reel of my life
because he told me, he said your, he saw me,
he saw himself probably in me
and saw exactly the path I was on and
wanted to tell me, but also wanted to tell me that
I still had to go down the path.
Right, so,
was there a specific moment where it dawned upon you
or was it a kind of a slow realization.
A slow realization.
And did you
pick up the phone and call Ted and tell him
I've arrived.
I've arrived, now what?
And the bag is indeed not full.
It's not full.
No, it was really more of a slow
process and I think that in
a lot of life transformations, I think, happens,
you know, kind of over time.
I think things just start losing their luster,
you start losing a little bit excitement
or energy around things.
You start realizing
that something's a little bit more shallow
than you than you realize before.
And the cumulative effect, you start just to
energetically wake up and not have that same passion
and enthusiasm and optimism that you built your life around
and that can be a pretty scary place.
So, yeah, it was over time,
over about two year period of time for me.
The things that were holding me back
was not paying attention to the little things in my life,
the internal things, I was so externally focused
that I wasn't really taking care of myself,
not just in some of the traditional self care ways that
we kind of spoke about at the beginning,
but some very specific practices that there have been
kind of double placebo studies at universities show
have a benefit on how people's energy levels are,
or how their sleep is or their, you know,
kind of mental outlook of
the future being better than the past and so
what I found was,
even though I tried so many different things
and met with so many different people, the,
what made the biggest difference
was actually working on the simplest things
and just like really dialing in some simple things like
the power of my breath or spending time in nature
and why that's important for my brain or
how your mindset can change through neuroplasticity and
those little simple things that I worked on
is what had the biggest effect and
over time is that really started to,
kind of, give me and ground me
in feeling like I was more in control
with how I woke up and felt every day,
that's what led to and I think that's where
the disposition of that had
caused me to start telling myself, okay,
how can I help as many people learn this too
because there are a lot of people, I mean
out there suffering, I mean,
you can read any headline in the news now and you see that
we have more people on antidepressants
than ever in the history of America
and more people taking sleep aids
just to get a night's sleep, I mean,
we are as a society suffering
and having experienced some of that suffering
really motivated me to, you know
wanna do something to help people not have that
suffering is not necessary.
Yeah 100%.
I walked away from the sport 'cause I was
tired of the politics and the feelings that I got about
my worth as a human being and my body and my,
like, I was just tired, I just needed to get away,
like it was so exhausting to always feel like I was like
an object of, or a project or you know, something that
I couldn't figure out how to find my love for it again,
so, like, why not just run away?
I don't wanna keep trying and forcing this
if I'm just gonna feel angry at it,
and that was my reason for stopping, I was tired.
I was tired of what was going on,
I was tired of feeling like I was just,
like I said, this object or this project or not enough or
needed to be somebody for these coaches or these people,
I just like, wanted to be,
and it was such a powerful feeling within me
that I was just so tired of that,
and so, I just ran away (laughs)
and that's when I had a lot of different things happening.
Right.
But I fully ended my career
on a very intense, like,
bodily feeling that I had to go.
Right.
Like I had to go,
like, it was just too much for me.
And also like
that, I knew that I did what
I got out what I put in,
you know, that I got what I came for.
I did what I wanted to do as a little girl.
On the pool deck.
Yeah.
But, oh, I just feel it in my body when I talk about that,
'cause that moment,
that moment was so powerful.
I was sitting on the side of the pool
and I was ending this thing,
it's like you're breaking up
with this thing you've been with for 25 years or whatever
and it was just this,
this is how it is?
This is how it's gonna end,
just kind of petering out in a local meat.
Yeah.
With a subpar performance.
Yeah,
subpar performance, really not good and
proud of myself for continuing, but, you know
I just wanted to prove myself and when I realized that
I just didn't need to be in it anymore.
I needed to find something else and I knew that I could,
and I knew that I could be rebirth in my life
and I had that feeling that that would happen.
I just didn't know how.
Yeah.
I had no idea how, I had no idea what I was gonna do.
So,
that process of
on some level reliving those experiences or just
emotionally confronting them,
I mean, that's required if you're gonna heal, right?
Like you've gotta walk through that process,
so, what was the methodology or the technique,
like was it a specific, like,
is it behavioral cognitive therapy or what kind of vein
were you exploring this in?
So, it's called somatic experiencing SE and
Peter Levine started it,
I don't know if you've ever heard of Peter Levine?
I feel like you would love this field by the way
if you kind of dive into some of the SE stuff
and more of the.
I had Andrew Huberman in here talking about some of the
you know, techniques that they use, like,
you know with the way that you move your rapid eye movement
and stuff like that and how that helps you rewire
some of your neurochemistry.
Exactly, so, you're
basically rewiring your entire nervous system
to think and to feel something different that you
haven't ever felt before,
and your body's gonna wanna not do it.
You know, not gonna wanna do it.
So, half the time we have to stop and start over
but it's a lot of rapid eye movement stuff, it's a lot
like, would it be like ventral things
where you're like holding different parts of your body,
you recount, you say the event again out loud and
you should like take notes
on what parts of your body were tensing during that process
so that you can then realize what parts of your body
are holding onto that trauma
and then you do work on like releasing that area
and letting that go because that's real,
I mean, it's stored in specific parts of our body.
Minor hips and feet and lower extremities.
So, that's a big part of it, also just essentially
like I did a lot of like actual active work,
so, when I would go in with Sarah,
I would stay on the opposite side of the room
she would stay on the opposite side of the room,
I would walk a little bit closer
and she would do certain things to like
come toward me or act a certain way and whatever happened,
I would have to stop and explain what that,
what showed up for me in that moment, or like what happened?
And it's, I mean, there's days when I would just be like
(screams) like just sobbing my eyes out,
but like the whole point of this
is to let your system get rid of it
so that you can then create space for it to rewire.
So, you have to start by like,
sweeping, like getting rid of it, bringing it up,
letting it out and then rewiring it and so, now I'm like,
I see her like once a month, it's you know,
so we've really weaned down, but you know.
At your peak, how often were you having these sessions?
Three days a week.
Oh, really?
(both laughing)
I was like, well,
I'm either gonna pay for it now or pay for it later, so,
I'm sick of running, I was sick of my own bullshit,
I was sick of getting injured,
I was sick of seeing all these symptoms pop up when really
the issue was that I hadn't chosen to heal myself,
I had chosen to run.
I had chosen to continue to follow the same pattern I did
since I was a little girl and it's just, where can I run?
What can I do to just not be seen
and just make everybody happy and do all these things?
Like no, I need to choose myself
for the first time in a really long time
and I can't make excuses anymore.
I can't just be like, oh, this happened to me.
It's like, no, it's not,
it's not working for me anymore.
It's super powerful and I love how
basically, you know, your life directed you towards this
by stripping you down, right?
This was your divine moment.
Like you were being compelled to confront this,
one way or the other
and had you continued to be in denial
or refuse to engage with this,
you know, some kind of therapeutic process,
your life was gonna continue to decline,
like your body was gonna continue to break down,
it just was a matter of how much pain
are you willing to sit with before you're actually gonna
engage with this and like grapple with these issues.
And here's the thing is,
as women, as men as well, but you pass on
everything that you have not healed.
Your system and your cells actually hold trauma
and they will actually continue to carry that on.
I don't wanna have children and pass that on to them.
I don't wanna be harboring resentment and anger and you know
all of it and pass it on to the next generation,
I don't wanna do that.
So, I sort of view my purpose in life
as being able to heal so the next generations
can continue to heal,
regardless of if I have my own children or not,
like that's my whole mission is how can you
create space for people to know that they're able to be
whatever they can be
if they can really work on healing
their mind and their body together, it's possible.
It's just weird for people to understand at first.
It's not, it's nuanced.
It's not.
Well, it gives the work that you do
so much more resonance now
like with Rise athletes and the, you know,
these young Athletes that you
and Rebecca are mentoring.
Now that you've, you know undergone this experience,
like there's so much more depth to what you can convey.
Yeah.
In these relationships.
And everything has started to make sense, you know.
It's all been the same thing,
it's just shown up in all of these different ways
in different places, which I think if we look at our lives
and we see a thread tied through them,
it's usually that thread is one thing that
everything keeps mirroring whatever it is
in one way or in one direction or another, you know?
So, for mine, it was this people pleasing thing
that needed to be fixed, but then as it started to heal
it's this mind body thing where, okay,
your whole life has been surrounded about being a feeler,
so, now let's use that to your advantage
instead of using it as you can only please people,
let's use it as a way to be in this world,
as a way to change and make change, you know.
What a relief.
And it finally all made sense,
I was like, I'm not weird, I'm not weird,
it's just who I am and that's okay
and I don't need to apologize for it anymore.
And what a gift that your body broke down or that you,
you know, had the traumas that you had
so that you were given the opportunity to confront this
because, short of that, you can live your whole life
kind of, you know,
babysitting these character defects on the back burner,
but nothing severe enough ever happens
that compels you to look at it
to the deep extent to which you have,
so, ultimately you become the stronger, better, person
because of your pain.
Yeah, and I've had some people ask me things like,
well, what if nothing's really happened to me
to where it's like allowed me to see certain things,
it's like I know they're there
but nothing's really happened to push me into that place
that's like really bad to where I need to figure this out.
And it's a great question
and I don't necessarily know that it has to be that way,
I think what we...
Makes it easier.
It makes it way easier.
To think people ask me that question,
I'm like, I don't know what to tell you, because like,
I just was in so much pain,
I didn't feel like I had any other choice.
That choice is available to all of us at any moment,
it's just harder to make that choice
when you're not suffering.
Yeah.
Because who wants to do that kind of work?
Suffering really does lead you to that too.
And if you feel like you don't need to,
it's like, I got shit to do.
Right, you'll continue to, right,
and so, I guess the only thing
that I could really think to say
to someone in that position is like, you know,
maybe you're just trying to think about it too much
and you really have to see what your body is telling you,
because our bodies are actually giving us
so much information, that we completely ignore.